l'entrée thématique commission karl
lagerfeld car le 15 et on a fait tous
les cas il y avait carl lang n'a pas
voulu être
ces trois quarts marche il est mort donc
voilà on fait un spécial car l'absolu
alors karl largerfeld une hyper view
vérité 1 alors l'hyper view c'est déjà
quelque chose du tout ces gens là vont
vous poser des questions
l'hyper you vérité c'est que vous
engagez bien entendu à dire la vérité
comme marie laforêt vient de le faire a
dit toute la vérité voilà alors ce qu'on
peut dire déjà pour commencer c'est que
vous avez réussi beaucoup de choses mais
surtout à imposer une image c'est à dire
vous êtes vous êtes un logotype vous
êtes une icône quoi quand on voit
qu'elle quand on voit des lunettes
noires un catogan et un éventail et puis
l'éventail non parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut larguer les accessoires
away le gênant vous avez abandonné
l'éventail c'est fini oui je l'avais
pris pour une raison plus la vie
différente et pas pour faire une image
ouais je ne fume pas oui un débat digne
de la fumée des autres c'était seul
moyen pour s'en débarrasser d'accord les
gens fument moins j'ai pas besoin
d'accords cicos allume-cigare on va vous
prêter un ventilo passerez les cigares
cigarillos ça me gêne moins que les
cigarettes bonbons tu peux y aller jean
pierre alors donc même effectivement
même si les gens savent pas toujours
très bien ce que vous faites ils savent
que vous êtes karl lagerfeld voilà c'est
une réussite comme une autre avec des
enclos de gênant qu'autre chose aussi mr
fab ont justement fait beaucoup beaucoup
de choses
alors là il ya un truc qui s'est passé
c'est que dans toutes vos sociétés dans
toutes vos activités
il ya eu une qui s'appelait qu'à elle et
qui a fait 2 k déposé son bilan qui
avait fait faillite c'est plus humain ne
peut pas y tue tout ça faisait partie
d'un groupe avec lequel s'était associé
qui est groupe vendôme et avec qui je
m'entendais pas du tout et je voulais
qu'une chose elle a démandé brasser et
j'ai récupéré tout mon nom je vais
récupérer votre nom voilà c'est ce que
je voulais voilà même temps tous mes
autres sociétés et puis je l'algérie est
pas oui et donc gérer pas vous societe
vous toucher des royalties
oui mais il est monsieur qu'il a géré il
vient d'être remercié parentaux
malheureusement donc ça développe pas de
si génial alors la société ces bandeaux
donc la société cas elles n'existent
plus les
une nouvelle qui l'avait live gallery
lagarfeld galerie des galeries à paris
qui voit la new york et qui est nul à
monaco
voilà alors ses 48 scène donc c'était
comme vous avez fait ça avec andrée
putman pourrait commencer à cambrai
pullman reviennent avoir eu
effectivement à new york à berlin monaco
voilà c'est tout votre monde à vous ah
oui mais il ya personne qui me dit de
faire ça ça ça c'est une chose à moi
personnellement avec mes propres sous et
ça m'amuse beaucoup plus parce que en
même temps ça doit être différent de mes
gros client c'est à dire chanel et fendi
vrai que je veux pas être concurrents de
mes clients oui temps j'ai fait autre
chose à y ait de la mode on peut on
nommer de la mode il ya déjà des livres
il ya des photos puisque vous êtes on en
parlera vous êtes devront prendre les
choses que je fais l'italie profonde il
ya dans les parties qu'on vend là aussi
puisque pour le moment il ya ce fameux
sac baguette de pain dit qu'elle ne
savait plus vendu du monde donc on ne
vend là aussi le sac baguette
annabelle baguette qu'est ce que c'est à
dire ça qu'ils se mettraient près du
sous le bras et se voit quelqu'un l'a
appelée baguette un jour il est devenu
de sac baguette
voilà le plus forte pour le saluer
mais passé un nombre tout le monde s est
agacé on peut pas marcher
c'est déjà journée des files d'attenté
des 10 des attentes après l'émission
elle vous l'a foot sous le bras au lieu
donc bon alors là vous êtes devenu alors
ce qui est incroyable c'est devenu un
photographe vous a vu les photos et
l'idée de carl à mesure que vous êtes
devenu s'est passé si regardez j'ai même
les membres est certes vous ai commencé
à faire des photos il ya 13 ans design
passer ça et vous êtes devenu
photographe mais maintenant les journaux
du monde entier vous réclame pour faire
des photos je pourrais arrêter la sphère
la mode même si je voulais oui c'est
assez d'argent avec la photo pour ce pas
question vous et moi je ne travaille
plus pour gagner de l'argent car quand
vous étiez quand vous étiez petit vous
vouliez déjà être portraitistes
caricaturistes des cadres et supporte le
titre est le désir vous saviez
énormément quand vous étiez petit déjà
qu'on vous a surnommé le kaiser de la
mode mais d'alcool pâte a jeté plus tôt
déjà c'est déjà ce que ce que ce que
vous vouliez faire c'est idiot mais je
n'ai jamais changé d'idée oui alors vous
êtes allemand j'arrive je crois que je
crois tout le monde ici peut le
constater
karl lagerfeld et allemands je pense que
petit retard et ça peut-être votre bague
non j'ai alors qu'adp en 40 il était
alors qu'à j'ai quand même quelques
influences étrangères d'origine qui font
que j'ai pas lui c'est terrible vous y
êtes en mai en france vous êtes à jour
il expliqué parce que c'est parce qu'il
arrivait un petit peu de retard
oui mais c'est pas grave tu me veux tu
sais qu'ils sont ouverts mais pourquoi
vous vous êtes pas encore excusé de nous
d'abord personne puisque vous étiez en
train humide interview m arrive à témoin
est donc un an parce qu'on demande aux
cayes jean pierre dit oui c'est vrai il
n'a pas dit pardon c'est bien quand il
arrive dans l'impression de déranger pas
de vous avoir
alors on a juste attendu une demi-heure
en france vous êtes car en france vous
êtes l'horrible allemand et en allemagne
vous êtes celui qui est parti donc
visitent le salon voire voulait dire oui
je sais bien le seul endroit où je me
sens étranger c'est mon pays oui c'est
vrai vous aimez pas l'allemagne c'est
pas sympa l'allemagne mais comme j'ai
presque jamais vécu en allemagne que je
vis ailleurs depuis que j'ai 14 ans
c'est assez particulier pour moi parce
que au fait j'ai pas parfaitement
allemand je comprends que trop tout ça
mais en même temps je n'ai pas
l'impression de faire partie de ça oui
comme c'est un enfant vous étiez vous
aviez une mentalité d'adultes à ces
jeunes haïtiens les enfants quand
j'étais en voilà et vous vous détestiez
doutons pas que j'étais déjà assez
infernal dont nous étions enfants parce
que ces messieurs à l'âge de 5 ans vous
exigez un valet et des boutons de
manchette
oui c'est quand même assez comment père
ah oui à 15 ans venait à paris et votre
votre mère vous dit votre père dire je
ne sais pas vous dis ne soit jamais
danseurs ou prêtres pourquoi mais ma
mère est de tester ses deux métiers pour
un homme ah oui et si le fait que je
suis devenu couturier s'est pas non il
ne dit pas si ce métier m'a dit non
c'est bien de faire ça ça prouve t pas
snob qui n'en ferait pas un horrible
métier comme ça à l'époque ce métier
n'avait pas très bonne presse ces piles
on a arrangé ça va ils ont leur être
apportées alors maintenant premier prix
donc j'ai eu le premier prix d'un
concours concours international de là
l'aisne avec un petit manteau cheville
aux jo mais ça fait toujours sourire et
le manteau a été réalisée par bellemare
est devenue l'assistante d'allemagne
donc le succès absolument pas là
assistant d'un couturier 14 16 17 ans
c'est bien mais c'est pas le succès le
lien à l'époque c'est l'argent qui va
être à 620 couture et oui d'accord mais
à l'époque c'était plus dans des villes
est passé lui aussi en moi et c'est un
peu pareil pour vous c'est directement
de facteurs acteurs comme une lettre à
la lettre à la poste
c'était très facile moi j'admire bon
rendu les gens pour qui c'était
extrêmement facile oui alors votre a
gagné ce concours donc vous hills alors
en lui il avait dessiné une robe et vous
un manteau ça vous a pas rendu jaloux de
saint laurent soit star 20 ans avant
vous non non pas du tout parce que moi
j'avais d'autres priorités que lui
n'avait pas lutter beaucoup plus
ambitieux que moi oui dans une pratique
tout ça m'a pas gêné du tout du tout du
tout du tout j'aimerais pas à sa place
aujourd'hui
avant pourquoi pour d'autres multiples
raisons parce que c'est pas moi papa de
lui donc je n'ai pas eu d'accord avec
vous les discrets quand même oui
ouais c'est bien ça vous puissiez toute
façon c'est une émission d'une
discrétion tout le temps est venu pour
elle c'est même un truc qui fait la
réputation de l'émission gens disent
bien faire on va chez ardisson parce que
moi on posera pas d'élection personnel
parce que je suis tellement content
d'être là alors vous êtes vous êtes un
peu certes que s'ouvre aux airs comme ça
un peu grand seigneur et à travailler
beaucoup vite commenté cette notion de
travailler beaucoup et quand enfin me
quitte pas de différence entre votre vie
privée vie professionnelle en fait il
n'y en a pas parce que je ne crois pas
que ça existe parce que si on me fait
des séparations sa foi d'un côté à
l'autre
ouais ben ali nous prenez tout ouïe est
ce que le ballon d'or tous se mettent
d'accord
oui parce que pour une fois on pourrait
être tous d'accord sacha d'achat j'aime
ces moments où on partage nous parle je
ne vois pas aussi dit travailler à
l'amateur rencontre à l'avantagé des
tènements au regard de votre gueule la
coff se fout de ma gueule je connais
aussi sous le maillot de rugby
je suis pas pu lui dire tu vois et
l'autre avec tout mais craig fait on
pourrait si le réveiller jean-pierre oui
oui mcdonnell posé de questions je
devrais je faisais ça c'est de l'humour
vous fois une attaque jean faire
réveiller je vous ai quelques fois connu
du brion nous pas méchante mais bon à
mon avis de la télé si vous en avez si
je perds j'essaie de vous réveiller je
sais que j'aime mieux me réveillais
j'écoute ce qu'il dit est intéressant
garde aux écoutes et j'ai pas de raison
d'intervenir j'ai écouté ben moi j'ai de
la forêt alors écoutons cavani carlo il
est d'ailleurs j'ai vous génez pas
messieurs des mondiaux et nous vous en
remercions vous êtes des millions à
écouter ce que dit monsieur lagerfeld
alors vous travaillez vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure au travail pour chanel on
en parlera abstrait pour fendi fin dit
il faut le dire
pour les français c'est ses cinq soeurs
italiennes qui ont une maison de
fourrure absolument affluent
grande maison de fourrure aussi du monde
des sacs des choses de près on fait l
empire les modes de lens et bien vous
allez bonne conscience karl lagerfeld
parce que vous avez déclaré le vison est
une bête très méchante
il déteste l'homme comme ça finalement
quand on fait les manteaux haut niveau
vous savez l'histoire avec la fourrure
c'est bien gentil tous ses discours mais
il est une chose là bas d'autres hélas
il faut pas porter une cuillère il faut
pas manger de viande ça va loin de tout
ça et puis après je veux dire cette
cause aussi elle est très très mal
défendu par deux choses pas barbu d
horreur c'est le genre de la mode et où
déjà n'a plus envie de ne pas faire de
la fourrure des lapereaux qu'elles
soient pas contents et puis deuxièmement
aussi ces dames de son ordination qui
prêta c'est pas parce qu'on jette une
espèce d'animal mort sur une assiette de
mon amie anna wintour des voix aux
américains que nous on aurait renoncé à
faire la fourrure parce que les 10
millions ça fait pas partie des choses
qui m'impressionne l'anneau donc cédé
très très mauvaise cause il ya plus de
vaches queues de vison
oui d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut les supprimer plus vite les
bastiais n'a plus non non mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fait c'est rien
c'est qu'elle n'en garde car dans ce cas
à quoi ils forment un interview sur arte
à mu avait dit qu'après tout la fourrure
c'est jamais qu'une housse à viande mais
sané qu'est ce que c'est d'autre oui ça
donne vachement envie de porter de la
fourrure comme marché de la viande je
veux dire c'est pareil cas là oui j'ai
la viande non mais arrêtez paris les
antilles manche va bien j'aime pas ça
j'aime le jem le poisson du jury car ce
que vous montrez une publicité contre la
fourrure et après vous les prenez tous
les cons n'est pas les gens les mains